[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Sam in Michigan
Uncle Dave I'm 37 married with no kids
yet my net worth is $1.1 million 600 in
portfolio 500 in equity in my home which
is worth 900 I make about $200,000 a
year have no Consumer Debt and have our
thre Monon emergency fund I just got
into hunting and there's several
shotguns and rifles I want but the misss
doesn't see why I need so many guns
Uncle day being a man of great means
with many guns what is a fair ratio he
said I'm also about to pull the trigger
on a new lond Rebel XL as my first
fishing and hunting boat it's 39,000 out
the door I'm paying cash for it but
would be pulling the money from my
portfolio to do so I feel it passes the
burn it on the floor test what is your
take thanks so much for your time this
is a fun question live like no one else
so later you get to live and give like
no one else well done Sam in michig yeah
that's fun that's fun Sam the only thing
I'll tell you is is that there seems to
be a a Rao that every time I get a gun
she gets a new expensive
purse TI for Tat there seems to be a
tradeoff there so um that's the only
thing I'll tell you all I heard here was
about you buying stuff I didn't hear
anything about her getting stuff so I
think there's some uh some enjoyment
with money that you're learning to do
that is within reason and um it's not a
certain number but uh I'll all getting
aside it actually does generally cost me
a purse depending on the gun so uh or
something else but yeah um I'm going to
get one of it's like Revenge spending
right yeah none of this has to do with
money this is just her feelings about
him owning all of this all these toys I
can tell you Sharon has exactly the same
opinion she has absolutely has no need
to understand why I need all these
Firearms but she doesn't know about
zombies
that's right the zombie apocalypse I
mean you have to be ready so um no
seriously dude it's just a toy it's just
a thing uh I mean
uh whether it's whether you're
collecting guns whether you're
collecting uh whatever the hobby is
whatever your hobby is whatever the
thing is you collect whatever the thing
you enjoy doing hunting uh you know
boats skiing fishing whatever the trick
is just to keep it in balance and that
both of you have a say so so I all all
joking aside I still do talk to Sharon
we don't do any purchases around our
place without both of us being in on it
I don't walk in and go I just spend
$8,000 I don't do that um I could but it
just doesn't it's not how we got here
the way we got here is working together
and both of us communicating and talking
about it and she doesn't go spend $8,000
on a whatever without talking to me and
you know we and but 99% of the time it's
like yeah sure because it's it's it fits
the burn test of can burn that much
moneyy in the middle of the floor that
means we can enjoy the item it's not
going to cause us financial trouble
we're not buying it for someone else we
don't we quit doing that a long you the
right motive yeah so and he's not he's
not buying these guns for someone else
he's buying them for him so uh so is the
key here you know Dave doesn't have to
Value all the things Sharon values and
Sharon doesn't have to Value all the
things Dave values but there's
communication involved and she goes okay
it's in the budget you're probably
experiencing this around purchasing
things for the new baby oh yes there are
things that you don't understand I don't
you know most men don't understand China
cabinets I still don't we don't
understand China that we don't use and
we don't understand a expensive cabinet
to put it in none of this makes sense to
us it was up to me we just use paper
plates just throw them see there you go
and if it was up to her he'd have a BB
gun that's right so there you go so I
mean it's just there there's some things
like you don't have to understand
everything to see that your spouse gets
Joy from it and that it is a reasonable
purchase within the thing now where we
do run into trouble when someone buys a
boat puts it on
payments that you know they got $60,000
in credit card debt and they want to buy
an $8,000 shotgun now that's just that's
childish that adds Financial stress to
the family yeah that's that's not that's
the opposite of what we're talking about
he's got a million dollar net worth he's
37 years old so he can afford a shotgun
or she can afford a nice purse or
whatever the thing is that you're
worried about there uh the trick is when
you get out of control with it so you're
just trying to do that and uh I mean TR
I'm kidding around I'm being snarky
about it but it's really no joke there
are things that I buy that Sharon agrees
to but has
no understanding why I want them at all
and the same with her I'm like you want
to do you know what I mean she took a
trip with a bunch of girls this summer
and I'm like really there you want to go
there but it I'm not going so what do I
care she wanted to go it's her
experience you let her have it that
that's the thing so just just hold
things with an open hand but I I I the
the the biggest glaring thing I see in
this Sam is not whether you can afford
to do it uh is that you didn't mention a
single thing that she gets to do while
you're doing all these things and you
really do have to have some what of a
balance it's not Tit for Tat exactly you
know like
$4,620 I get she get to spend $39,000
purse that's yeah
that's it could happen but um yeah yeah
so there you go I mean that that you
just you don't have to understand
everything she do have to understand
everything can we do it and it doesn't
affect our family
negatively and do we still have room in
the budget to invest do we still have
room in the budget to
give if this goes sideways um has have I
caused myself a problem and none of that
none of that's here no do you see it no
I mean it looks good on paper it's more
the relational issue yeah you just left
out that I get called Uncle Dave twice
in the email I like that that's pretty
cool it's better than Grandpa Dave right
Papa Dave that's nice that's that's what
the grand kids caller the grand that's
not insulting Not For 37y Old Men well
there you go get Uncle for that there
you go I'll go with that create your
free every doll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life